[Music]
[Applause]
here's how the survey works we asked
three celebrities to complete a phrase
our first phrase was
instead of shaking hands i often greet
people with
matt kemp wrote a high five
howie mandel wrote a fist bump
lindsay lohan wrote the hood of my car
say hello to people yeah the fight
between chris brown and drake shows that
llc wrote hip-hop is a business fraught
with violence
drake wrote i'm no pushover
chris brown wrote i'm branching out to
guys
if they made a tv mini-series about my
life it would be called derek jeter
wrote heart of a champion
albert pujols wrote strength of a lion
roger clemens wrote balls of a hamster
very frank very frank of him stole my
title i punish
i punish my children by president obama
wrote taking away their dessert
john boehner wrote giving them a time
out
mitt romney wrote not telling them which
cayman island is holding their trust
fund
by the way
all five sons will be here tomorrow
[Applause]
probably asking for an explanation
i joined the gop because rick santorum
wrote i was inspired by ronald reagan
marco rubio wrote i believe in small
government
chris christie wrote i thought gop stood
for a garage of course
that's just
stupid wow
that would not be a good building no not
at all uh i never sent my kids to bed
without telling them liv tyler wrote i
love you
dana carvey wrote sweet dreams
barack obama wrote i killed osama bin
laden
[Applause]
[Music]
i love you i'll see you in the morning
and i killed him
kim kardashian and kanye west
charlie day wrote should not be dating
zoe deschanel wrote are a disaster
waiting to happen
the devil wrote is one of those wish i'd
thought of that
[Music]
[Applause]
that is the devil's headshot
it's amazing you could get a
questionnaire to him ah shut up
and then he um
we but we have the same publicist yeah
yeah before i was famous i worked as a
jennifer aniston wrote waitress
cheryl hines wrote bank teller
the octomom wrote parking garage oh
crowd's getting ugly start the car right
here
we
should be a little motorboat you and i
can escape
if the crowd turns on us
they went after the octo mom hey
i'm tired of people confusing me before
dylan mcdermott wrote dermot mulroney
iced tea wrote ice cube
steven tyler wrote a witch in an
armenian foot
and finally
finally if i ever get to meet god the
first thing i'd say is neil patrick
harris wrote thank you for my life
reese witherspoon wrote why must there
be suffering
larry king wrote i'm sorry i picked on
you in third grade
[Applause]